hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream number
44 no 45 q a
44. that was the last one oh this is
hard yes this is getting
specific it's the thinking that i find
difficult
no not usually no but this time this
this time with the smoke and the
endlessness of it all yeah thinking
through the smoke
yeah yeah yeah we do have for you some
cats in the background as usual which
much might help cgi cats they're not
real
don't worry no actual cats were fed for
this podcast
what are we hearing yeah so we're trying
to humidify the space such that if our
tech problems were about the dryness
we've got a steamer going in the
background oh no
we're revealing secrets yes the um the
frame drop signal failure that happened
last time
has continued to dog us it was not many
people suggested that it had something
to do with the frame rates
of the cameras that seemed very unlikely
for various reasons because
nothing had changed about the frame
rates and it happened on multiple
computers but
anyway we falsified that idea others
suggested that it might be related to
static electricity
so we've been humidifying the room which
is why it feels tropical in here
but in any case uh that does not seem to
have completely cured the problem so
we're not sure what's going on but
we will forge ahead we are forging yes
yes consider us forging
okay we have
couple of questions from last time a
couple of comments questions from
episode 44 and then we'll jump right in
to
this episode's questions uh first
is a comment i am an anarchist leftist
on the dyi
self-reliance free speech and
self-governance tradition
however i love your content greetings
from panama
so that's awesome green is from panama
exactly now i will say i'm not sure what
dyi means i thought maybe he meant diy
when i urban dictionary i
um i get doing yourself in which doesn't
seem to fit here
i don't i don't i hope not if so don't
do it just hang in there
you are you are you are you are loved um
but beyond that um i found this um i
found this lovely
i love i love getting these comments
from people who
um can identify some aspect of their
demographic that is far
different from what it is that uh we
apparently are and to say
um i love what you guys are doing yeah
that's awesome and
panama yeah what part of panama are you
in panama city
um we've spent a fair amount of time in
panama because that's where i did
graduate work um so anyway uh
fond of various parts of the country
it's very interesting place it sure is
do you have any views on decentralized
cryptocurrency like bitcoin
spit off the usual topics but i'm
interested in your reasoning
um i certainly have the sense
that um blockchain technology
and crypto has a great deal of potential
i'm certainly
thrilled at the idea of escaping debt
based
fiat currency and all of its evils um
that said i think you know we're in an
interesting spot where
these currencies are not so
straightforward and intuitive that they
are in a position to replace
our more mainstream currencies so anyway
i'm waiting to see something break out
in this space i'm also waiting to see
some sort of a confluence between
blockchain
crypto space and game b idw
unity open source maker movement
all of these things are aspects of the
same
new world trying to be born and i'm
waiting for them to find each other and
discover that they
speak different versions of the same
language well there are tendrils that
have found each other behind the scenes
we know
um but it's it has not yet come together
in a giant convergence
yes the convergence has to happen yes uh
it's overdue
is it possible that donald trump's
superpower is getting corrupt
politicians to raise a flag saying i am
not here to help the people
thereby pointing out the rot that should
be removed
i found that a fascinating comment yeah
um
you know i think the tragedy
of the moment or part of it is that
donald trump
does have very unusual
skills and he's got very unusual
deficits and i think there's a
temptation on the part of those who see
his
um political capacity and understand
that it is causing all sorts of crazy
things to reveal themselves elsewhere
and they see that as positive
as do i um that they look past
the very substantial negatives which
that's where we part company and i would
say um
look he beat half the duopoly that's an
amazing accomplishment
it's i can't tell you how resilient the
duopoly is and for him to have done that
is an amazing
which half are you imagining he beat
because in some by some reckonings he
beat both abs
well you know the thing is the democrats
being the democrats they kind of beat
themselves
they did i mean if you don't believe me
people hear this and they think
what is he saying he's a he's a lefty
and i am a lefty but
um but if you look up the term pied
piper candidate and you look at the
emails
it's quite clear that hillary clinton
thought that donald trump was the
candidate she wanted to face
and so so easy to beat right um
so they used surrogates in the press to
advance his candidacy
so when you say that he beat half the
duopoly you mean that he uh
he smuggled himself in he's not very
good at smuggling himself he
crashed crashed in through the wall to
the republican party
and they started trying to go don't
don't what are you doing and then they
ultimately caved yeah i mean he
he bust in on the republican
racket and they could have
rebelled but instead they bent the knee
and you know it's a very interesting
story
it's a very remarkable accomplishment
but
it's not the whole tale and the problem
is that the characteristics necessary to
accomplish that
are i believe not consistent
with the kind of um nonpartisan
leadership that we need
at a moment in which we face this level
of divisiveness
okay one more um just light-hearted
question from last time someone asked if
um either of us have a favorite font for
writing
and if they are the same or if we have
font debates
and we've never actually talked about
this i'm not sure you have any
opinion at all uh i i do
i always d i always use palatino
and my mother who was a calligrapher for
several years while i was growing up
um instilled in me still a love of the
letter form
and although as a as a left-hander i was
never going to become
excellent with ink and a pen because um
at least not
using um using english if it'd be one
thing if i was trying to write
in a language that went right to left um
but but palatino for me and i don't know
if
i don't honestly know if you have an
opinion ah it's wingdings all the way
no you know i'll tell you what let's i'm
gonna answer the question
this is not an insult to your question
but i'm gonna answer the question i
think you should have asked rather than
the question that you actually asked
um so i do have a couple of interesting
relationships with the idea of font one
is i'm very fond of the idea that font
became a thing
um in the way that it did because of
um steve jobs steve jobs who dropped out
of college and kept going and took a
class on calligraphy and anyway read
right at reed exactly
exactly um so there's something
marvelous about that story and it
connects to our
uh experience in multiple ways we had
students
who after they had graduated kept
attending our classes who we called
drop-ins following what steve jobs had
described himself as doing so that's one
sort of thread
sort of the aesthetic flair that the
the guy who had the insight about um so
much in the space of computers
and just reminding us that design is
actually everywhere
and that you don't tend to notice good
design you almost always notice bad
design even if not consciously
but that he he brought to us the amazing
uh the myriad choices of fonts um to
some degree
uh that we have some of which are
obviously ugly and bad and there's you
know there's plenty of font wars
out there but um but
probably the history of early personal
computing would look
much different and it would have taken
off uh with different kinds of people
being core users
had there not been the design in
font's attention paid due to steve jobs
early
experiences i would agree with that and
i would say
also at the level of the how might we
upgrade our
system of governance
it looms very large for me that
government needs to regulate us in a way
that
is so light-handed and elegant that we
don't detect it the way you don't detect
all of the inner workings of your
computer if the interface is well
designed
and then the last thing i'll say is that
crazy typewriter over in the corner
um which i've told the story of a little
bit but i got that thing for 11 bucks at
a goodwill
thinking i would um hack into the
keyboard and turn it into a
printer and then i discovered there was
no electronics to hack into in that
machine
and i fell into it for a number of
months and again what it is
oh it's a selectric 2 correcting
selectric 2.
an amazing device and a whole world of
people that's
dying at an incredible rate this team of
technicians that ibm trained to be able
to service that thing because it's so
complex
um you know some of those people are
still around and they you know they
serviced a very smaller number of these
things
but anyway the thing about that
typewriter was that it was built around
this ball
that solved the problem of the keys of
the typewriter sticking with each other
if you hit two letters too close
together which is of course the reason
that the keyboard is such a crazy
organization of letters was to slow down
the typist so they were less likely to
jam the keys of the original
um electro electric typewriters or any
typewriter
but which you're talking about qwerty
keyboard as opposed to like dvorak
right so the qwerty keyboard was
actually designed to slow you down um
slow you down so you didn't
jam the keys that uh
ball typewriter um solves the problem
there are no keys it has a ball that
leaps and hits the page at the right
spot to get the right letter
leaps and spins it leaps and spins it's
the most amazing device ever because
it's all mechanical except for the motor
and the switch
and anyway you could replace the ball so
unlike a regular typewriter you can
change the font that's really where
fonts became a thing for somebody you
know it wasn't really similar this would
have been
late 70s early 80s early 80s mid 80s
when that one
is i believe a late 70s
late 70s maybe it's early 80s but um but
anyway
the balls they're you know they're still
available on ebay and stuff
and there are a couple of them that i
find captivating there's one which i
can't get the right spacing for but
there's one they had which actually does
cursive
and so basically the cursive was made so
that the ending of one letter
lines up with the beginning of the next
letter so if you get the typewriter that
has the correct spacing
it will write a cursive um page for you
and it's pretty
freaking compelling that's amazing
because obviously there are different
widths i mean so i have i have
in college played around a lot with sort
of movable type and
and uh broadsheets and you've done some
print making and such
and you know we know that um there's
just there's there's different widths to
letters for words to look
reasonable yep um so the idea that you
could do cursive would seem
to presume that either the typewriter
already knows what you're about to type
which it presumably can't
or it has um controlled for what such
all of the wits are the same yeah what
they've done somebody spent a lot of
time
designing the font so that it uh
solved the problem of wits and left it
readable yeah
and anyway the first time i saw a page
that had been typed out on this thing i
was just
stunned at how compelling it actually
was and
you know what that suggested also about
you know there was a way in which
you know early printers had a very harsh
look you know dot matrix printers
like they were you know personal letter
on a dot matrix printer is just
you know a uh it's hard to write a
compelling
love letter on a dot matrix printer
don't i know it yeah
but yes so um so the idea that um this
printer
involved or this uh typewriter involved
the ability
and that somebody would be inclined to
design a font that would actually
um have that that leave the the reader
with that impression
i don't know captured my imagination so
yeah
so you know we could we could talk about
fonts for a while but maybe maybe we
won't man i think you know
i feel like i've said when i need to i
could keep talking you could keep
talking about fonts
um okay first question from today
john baez world class mathematician was
recently cancelled for a joke about
obscure algebraic structures
jokingly calling them oppressed in math
bullying rose so high he deleted the
joke left twitter he is a great mind i
will miss hearing his ideas live
do you have thoughts i only
barely know this has happened i only
barely
heard anything about this today so i
don't have many thoughts because i only
i know barely little than more than what
is being
said here do you know anything more um i
know this is the first
i've heard of it and i would say that is
such an upsetting description
um i mean i've said it so many times
before but you have to be free to make
jokes in order to navigate the difficult
stuff and
that means you have to have the ability
to make jokes
up through the border of what's
acceptable
in you know regular description and
um it's yeah and calling obscure
algebraic structures oppressed
is uh is clearly not at the limit of
what anyone should find
right exactly and you know to the extent
that it is offensive
the answer is thicker goddamn skin
yeah so what do you so it's easy to say
that and not to dismiss what you've just
said but what
not knowing really almost anything about
what this guy's situation was but what
should he have done then
uh in this case and i'm bullying what
we're told is bullying rose so high he
deleted the joke left twitter
um i'm getting more ornery on this front
um i i don't know this guy
yeah i'm i i feel for him but at some
level i think you have an
obligation to stand up to that level of
absurdity
right and you know you have to also just
have
a certain amount of trust that in the
end if somebody is accusing you
uh of some kind of bias or ism
for having called mathematical
structures oppressed
in what universe is that ever going to
stick right in what universe is anybody
actually going to believe you have some
sort of moral defect for having said
such a thing
increasingly this one but increasingly
this one because
most people when confronted with this
are so flabbergasted
uh that they shut it down i said this is
this is not
why i'm doing anything to deal with
these kinds of loons
and so i'm just gonna shut down my
social media and not deal with them
and um and i you know i get that
response for sure
but but it creates more of the universe
that none of us want to live in yes and
at some level i mean
maybe this is what needs to be said
there's a difference between
surrendering to these people
because you can't bear to listen to them
and
walking away from twitter and letting
them exhaust themselves doing whatever
they're going to do and
so rather than shutting your twitter
down just just like not going there for
a week or something
right i mean so walking away could mean
two different things here in one way he
has walked away you're saying the other
kind of walk away is what he should have
done
i think he needs to walk away strong he
doesn't have to sit there and listen to
them
i certainly understand i mean it's very
hard not to respond so
not engaging yeah is one thing but
i think the thing is we need to let
these people look like idiots because
that's what they are
and if what we do is we surrender out of
self-protection
each time this happens it's going to
keep happening
so in any case
i would ask him maybe reinstate his
account and let
whatever has happened there um remind us
of the fact that there is no bottom
when it comes to the stupidity these
people are willing to deploy
yep that's right okay
um totally here for sp i'm totally here
for speciation discussion
dive in please the speciation discussion
i did not know we were going to have a
speciation i didn't either and i'm not
sure
so i mean that's it's a little hard to
do from
zero i suppose you know we don't have
any context specifically
well we you know there's speciation
itself
is a large topic but there's also the
question of species concepts and i don't
know if
speciation is what uh he wants to hear
us riff on a little bit
yeah um so i'm trying to figure out in
real time
how to um deliver some chunk that will
be satisfying
um in my opinion the speciation question
is one that we have failed to answer
because we bought into some wrong
assumptions
early on in the discussion and um
that it's solvable but like with so many
of these things
solving it requires questioning the
assumptions rather than trying to take
the assumptions and just answer the
puzzle
even though it doesn't resolve and so um
the the basic problem is this we've got
different modes of speciation we've got
what we call allopatric speciation which
means
speciation in different places and we've
got
sympatric speciation which means a
population that is
in the same location turning into two
different species and
allopatric speciation we know happens
right it definitely happens as a matter
of fact all you have to do is separate
two populations for a long enough period
of time and even just the accumulation
of random changes will eventually make
them unrecognizable to each other
at first behaviorally if they're animals
and secondly molecularly if
they're not a river course diverts and a
population of 100
ungulates now has 80 on one side of the
river and 20 on the other
and if they don't if they can't swim if
they don't swim they don't cross the
river they will diverge over time that's
allopatric species if those populations
are too small they'll go extinct both of
them but
um but if we scale it up same same thing
um
the problem with sympatric speciation is
that
um it doesn't it's not easy to imagine
how it occurs because the amount of
gene flow between two populations that
has to occur to prevent
divergence is tiny we know this for sure
now that's pending certain assumptions
but the basic point is if you look at
something like the amazon
you've got evidence of a huge amount of
speciation it's the most specious
place on earth but you have very few
borders that would actually
constitute an obstacle to a creature
crossing
so if you think about the amazon the
amazon is not
mountainous it does have lots of rivers
and things in it but the most specious
things there are insects that fly
they're beetles
so why the heck are these tiny little
rivulets creating species divisions
between
populations of beetles well and there's
of course a question
of um you know at what scale are you
counting it as simpatric versus
allopatric and i think this is part of
part of maybe where you're going that
you know when we think on the scale of
mountains and rivers and such dividing
species and those being our indicators
of allopatry
it's both really easy to imagine because
that's exactly the scale that we live at
but it probably is not the scale at
which most of these things happen
and so you get niche partitioning within
a space
where you know you might have say
insects wood borers on a tree some of
which are boring
closer to the ground and some of which
up high um because the
you know the stuff that they're getting
from the tree is actually differently
accessible
um you know when the tree is you know
very thick at the bottom versus high at
the top
and so you get these insects
specializing within a single
place on the earth and yet they are
they're they're niche partitioning some
of these insects become ones that
specialize on lower some on higher parts
of the tree
it's a kind of allopatry if you think
about it the right spatial scale same
thing with the cichlids in the african
rift lakes right you've got
gosh i think it's hundreds of species of
these fish
that have speciated within in some cases
like feet of each other but they're
doing different things they're making
different use of the resources
um i don't think that's what's going on
with the african cichlids
it is in some cases um
well i i remain to be convinced that
that can happen on that scale
in an aquatic environment without
something else like fluctuating
water levels but um certainly there are
also fluctuating water levels that
explain
a lot of the speciation at least i think
two of the three lakes the african rift
lakes and africa i'd have to go back and
look to remind myself um and you know
your point about niche partitioning
is right in principle this can work it
has to be really the problem
that so this is going to get so tangled
the problem is fisher
gave us robust math that shows
just how little leakage between
populations you need to keep two
populations that are
initially alike from diverging and it's
almost nothing
but this is with respect to neutral
genes
yeah and the frequencies have to start
out alike
so anyway there are some some built-in
assumptions there but
um but this isn't really where the
problem is
um oh i did want to say my advisor dick
alexander
did create a model for what he called
allocronic speciation
which is a little bit like niche
partitioning in fact it is a kind of
niche partitioning but basically what it
had was species that are overlapping in
space
that breed at different times which
keeps them from
interbreeding well and you can also i
mean that also would work at the
circadian level so you could have
breeding at different times of the year
you'd also have activity levels being
diurnal versus crepuscular versus
nocturnal and we see all of these things
right
but again the problem with all of them
is that a little leakage is too much
leakage between populations is too much
and it's very hard to get zero
so i think there's a whole other way of
solving this puzzle
and this is the wrong place to do it but
i will say peripatric speciation is
going to be the answer and at some other
point i'll deploy
the mechanism by which it works but
allopatric speciation has two
populations that are
isolated from each other and simpatric
speciation is two populations
that are in the same place parapatric is
neighboring populations like two
countries that share a border
and um it is possible to explain things
like the amazon through parapatric
speciation
if you have a mechanism that keeps
things from sexually crossing the border
which we do um
so anyway a little tease at the end yep
all right
yeah uh everyone in the chat is saying
they would prefer the camera
to this webcam so do it yeah
okay so all right yep sorry about the
glitchiness we don't it looks more
normal from our end
yep um okay from an evolutionary point
of view
how come we're able to consume high
temperature foods and liquids without
much problem
does hot food occur naturally does it
come from a relationship with fire and
cooked food
if so do other species have more trouble
consuming hot
stuff it's a great question that is a
great question
um um okay yeah
so i mean i guess you know very fresh
meat
um is is warm um it's you know it's body
temperature obviously
yeah uh but it cools off quickly
and body temperature is body temperature
it's been
you know a small number of degrees so
that ought not cause us a problem
yeah um so you know does anyone else eat
anything that's warmer than body
temperature
um you know undoubtedly there are going
to be examples of
things that get you know
sit in the sun and baked in a
shell and sit on a hot surface on a rock
or something like that
but it's going to be pretty in general
not pretty rare also most creatures are
small and that means the things they eat
are small which means that the rate at
which they dissipate heat is large
or as high but i would say look
a long history of eating things from a
fire is going to result in selection
for resistance to being burned by hot
food
we are aided in this by virtue of being
so thoroughly
made of water because water has an
incredibly high specific heat
and that means it takes a lot of energy
to um
to raise the temperature of water and so
there's a you know there's a already a
built-in kind of safety because we are
made of water the same thing allows you
to walk over hot coals even though
that's not something your ancestor would
have done a lot of
if you don't linger too long the coals
are very
hot but they're not as full of energy as
you would imagine
and you can do it so being made of water
provides advantages
um the fact that you're interacting with
the hot food at a wet surface
also provides an advantage because what
service being your tongue and the inside
of your mouth
you know so in the same way that you
might burn your finger
if you touch the surface of a hot pan
but if you licked your finger
and you touch the surface you'll boil
off the water and that will give you
time to get away before you harm
yourself
that sort of thing uh but anyway yeah i
would say selection will have help and
what would i expect that selection to
have been
i would expect increased circulation
that is sensitive to the presence of
dangerously
hot food so the prediction is greater
vascularization in the mouth and tongue
of humans compared to
chimps and bonobos right but the obvious
killer app
for protecting yourself from food that's
been heated up
is going to be behavioral right
learning a what foods if you put them in
your mouth they're way too freaking hot
and so learning to blow on them learning
to wait
uh those things and
uh you know all of the little behaviors
if you do put something that's too hot
in your mouth or a whole you know the
stuff you do
yeah that thing you know you picked that
up somewhere
right now you may have learned it from
having burned you know gotten pizza
mouth and
you know whatever you do that prevents
that from happening it gets really
important anyone out there who's gotten
pizza mouth once and only once
i mean like that's actually one that
seems to be hard to learn perfectly from
somehow it's either testament to our
stupidity or just how very good pizza is
it is very good i mean it's also it's
not just good but it's geometrically
interesting ah that's true because you
think it's a triangle till you get to
the crust and then you've got this arc
and it's like one
different yeah hey zach yeah would you
let uh fairfax and he seems to be
yelling quite a lot
um it was all the talk of pizza he does
yes he does like himself some pizza that
cat does
okay i once dated a woman from awoke
university
one month then she informed me that we
could only be together short-term
because she wanted children
and under no circumstances would she
have an all-white child
oh my god was this learned and can it be
unlearned
seriously oh my god uh i mean this this
might
that's plausible i hope that you're
spoofing us here but oh my god oh no
that we have
she did you a favor that's true she did
she did run away run away is the right
advice and she did it for you
um yeah was this of course it was
learned
that kind of stupidity doesn't exist in
nature no one's born that dumb
yeah um oh look who's back um
wow yeah i don't know what else to say
beyond that is uh yeah can it be
unlearned
yes but it's gonna require some some
active unlearning and frankly it's not
your responsibility to teacher
yeah although more effective than
unlearning is just let selection
take care of this one i i don't
this level of stupidity is not
consistent with um
feeding themselves and uh they will get
what they deserve
you're forgetting about success between
men and women we will get what they
deserve
but yeah you're right but differential
reproductive success
being what it is she's likely to find
someone no matter what
yes yes that is true yeah okay judging
by andy no there are about five
protesters quote unquote arrested and
released in portland per day
with varying serious charges will there
be a surge of convictions in the next
two to five years
what do you think will happen um
well as i unders i've admit that since
the fires have happened i haven't been
paying as much attention but um
i understood that the d.a had said maybe
maybe with help from other authorities
uh that he was not going to be
convicting
any of the people arrested associated
with the protests and the riots
in portland which is in a totally insane
position
but that is that is what i where i
understand us to be
somehow i i i i'm speechless
yeah yeah i am prone to ranting go for
it
no i think it's probably best that i
don't but okay um
i i can't imagine you know we were just
talking about people
too dumb to reproduce and this strikes
me as the same level of dumb
where somehow you think civilization
continues even though you advertise
to the world at large that there are
certain rules they are allowed to break
as long as they do so under certain
banners
and those are some good rules they're
being allowed to break too like don't
set fire to people
and things that might have people in
them right those are really good rules
there it's really essential that we just
not be flexible about those rules and
yet we're being flexible about those
rules
um and anyway see earlier discussion of
why people who don't like donald trump
may end up voting for him because
this is just madness yep yeah to your
prediction from one or two live streams
ago the man's gonna win in a landslide
yeah which is something we've been
talking about for a few weeks now
yeah privately but i just i
i don't see how any other outcome is
remotely possible at this point
um i hope well i hope for unity
unity to unity yeah
the popcorn fallacy start with a kernel
of truth
add heat ideological spin raise the
temperature until it undergoes a phase
shift
pops so the kernel is no longer hard
reliable shelf stable etc
popped kernels aren't true
okay so the idea is yeah it was it was
true but
the phase shift um turns it into
something else
and it's still you know you can point to
it and say that's the same thing it just
it just looks different but um actually
some
uh fundamental structural changes happen
which is lost from any of its virtues
yes and at the place that you end the
thought experiment it has lost those
virtues without
gaining the virtues of salt and butter
true yeah now at the very least we could
add some
salt and butter yep okay
um thank you brett heather and the idw
for spreading free speech and thought
you
all are the intellectuals and
philosophers of our time thank you
questions your thoughts on the mbti
model
and how do you deal with blm apologism
i believe that was two very different
questions mbti is going to be
myers-briggs
or is there something else mbti uh you
you talk about blm while i look at mbti
wait what am i talking what am i saying
about vlm
uh um how do you deal with blm apologism
um yeah this is an incredibly
difficult and important question
myers-briggs okay um
blm apologism is a
destructive instinct that is endangering
everything and unfortunately the only
thing
that there is to do seems to be to talk
about
what is actually hidden inside of things
labeled with that very simple intuitive
um and appealing idea i mean i think
that's been the thing that we've begun
to to say most it's like
reveal to whoever you're talking to that
just because it has the nice sounding
name doesn't mean that's what it
actually is
yeah you know antifa is not anti-fascist
anti-racism is actually racist
black lives matter does not appear to
care about many black lives
despite having a name that would suggest
that that was exactly what it cared
about
the so in order to reach everybody and
maybe even the most important people to
reach
in this case you also need the other
side which is
the patriot act wasn't patriotic
everybody
understands that all of the people who
are somehow blinded by the idea that
anti-racism must be
the right thing now the example i use
here is pro-life
isn't particularly pro-life for for for
most of our perspectives over on the
left
um patriot act is more in keeping uh
because it's a political move yeah but
it's you know it's it's
as old as the hills that you would name
something in a way that makes it
difficult for people to say no to it
but at some level at the level that you
know if you're being manipulated by
people mislabeling things so that you
can't say no
then at some point you have to say no i
mean at some point like right away as
soon as you figure out that that's what
they're doing you have to say no
yeah so what do we think about
myers-briggs
um well i guess i'm
confused by what the quest is just
general yeah your thoughts um
you know so i was not compelled by
myers-briggs at all when i heard about
it the first time
and i was asked by a psychologist that i
was teaching with guy i quite
quite like um to take it and just see
what it said
and so i took it and i grumbled through
the entire
exercise of taking this thing at the way
these questions
were phrased in such a way that i didn't
think the right answer was presented and
so i couldn't very well
give the right answer and therefore i
was forced to pick an answer
that i didn't much like and then i got
my diagnosis
and it basically in telling a lot of
things that
matched my life pretty well described my
annoyance at the test i had just been
given
oh they're all going to guess yeah so
don't tell them yet let them guess no
they'll figure it out
um so he then uh your faculty colleague
also had all of your students do it yep
right and then you had
you did some seminars i believe around
like you talked about some of the
results
and you know said that way if i didn't
know you i could say you know it sounds
like you're talking about a
horoscope right like doesn't everyone
find what they want to find
in a horoscope yeah but in this case
description
was stuff like my fraught relationship
with my
phd uh process and all these it was too
specific to be that i mean i'm
very sensitive to the idea in fact i
love the idea of
predicting really off-the-cuff stuff and
you know in the off chance that it turns
out right then
you know it looks like you have insight
and so you know it's not
the kind of thing i would do but it is
the kind of thing that i
uh i understand how it works but in this
case
the diagnosis was spot on for me yeah
that said i have
given it to others and i mean there are
16 types
right um and i think there may be like
subtypes now but like
there's 16 types because there's four
four binary indicators so 16 possible
combinations and
um i don't remember what the ratios are
but there are you know a couple of
these personality types that are like oh
that's like 25 of the population or
something so
presumably for those that diagnosis is
going to be far
less predictive of who these people are
but for those of us
who the result is like oh you're less
than one percent of the population is
you know and
me you and i don't show up as the same
thing but both of us have some of these
you know very rare
um myers-briggs types um
it is more likely to say something
interesting if there's some fundamental
accuracy at base
right right now what i will say is that
i
when i was surprised by how closely it
had matched my experience
i gave it to others who did not have
that
experience and i know that people i
respect look at it and they say
um it you know it's nonsense and yeah so
i think psychologists are split
right so good good psychology
psychologists whom we respect
are split on this some people say it's
complete crap and some people
you know find it quite interesting and
useful including at a clinical level
uh but uh so that that suggests to me
that there's likely something there
it's not like all of the professionals
who we respect in the field understand
it to be terrible
but um you know some people think it's
useful under some circumstances no like
there's
there's you know there's there's good
professionals
who think it has validity yeah um
and i would say two things one it's
purpose originally myers and briggs were
i think
both females mother sister a mother
daughter mother daughter yep
and they designed this test i think it
derives from something jungian
i believe a less nuanced version of the
test or fewer axes or something but
um the test was designed
to find the proper vocation for people
post-world war two that's actually the
first time i was exposed to it was
as i was finishing my phd and i was like
huh let's just let's see i went into
like career counseling university of
michigan yeah they gave it to me
and so anyway one it's possible that it
works brilliantly for that because it
identifies something at that level
um i'm not saying it does but i'm saying
it's plausible that it does but that
when you
try to drag it into another realm like
how are we gonna relate interpersonally
that it's
a course or measure it's also possible
let's say
um that it's missing an axis
yeah right so that the real number would
be
you know 32 types right
yeah so just one more one more binary
right so if you have so if it's true
that there was another axis you could
add that would give you
30 uh two
bit resolution that's right that's right
maybe two to the fifth
then now i know the number's right i'm
just figuring out whether it means
it's accurate to say bit but in any case
if it were true that another axis would
get you high resolution
then what it would look like if you
subtract that axis is it would look like
kind of hit and miss it would have
validity
but it would you know group people
together of two different types that
weren't similar
yeah and so you might get this kind of
um you know
uh division between people who'd looked
at it and they say oh i've seen it
really work and then other people will
say no it's
complete nonsense yeah you would expect
that kind of reactions that's true
that's a good really good point
who knows what what's something that's
accurate
but not yet precise enough will look
like as a diagnostic tool
yeah yeah
i am a lapsed christian who rediscovered
faith this year
critical race theory rhetoric is
religion oh it is in religion
white christians have more original sin
must repent
to people to be saved uh your podcast
helps me spiritually now
thanks for every thanks forever and
everything you are doing
thank you thank you yeah i think that
actually that's right
i'm a little so i've heard two different
things
i hear a certain number of people
talking about
the religiosity of
critical race theory and all of its
descendants and i hear other people
talking
about wokeness moving
into christian circles yeah
and this i couldn't this actually says
crt rhetoric is in religion
um but i think ultimately this comment
is the first thing is the first thing
and not the second but nonetheless this
i mean you know and you would expect
based on the fact that there's an
analogy that there might be
an openness to this at a level that
there shouldn't be yeah you know
actually just driving past churches in
portland um i like a lot of the you know
when churches that have those like
placards out front where they have
inspirational sayings yeah
a lot of them are um pretty clearly woke
at this point and
part of that's you know don't don't
judge me don't hurt me signs but part of
it is actually
um them just you know feeling feeling
this
as something that's actually inclusive
and
healing as opposed to the divisive
rhetoric that it really is
well critical race theory has weaponized
people's
empathy against them and to the extent
that these
churches are built around you know
sort of cultivating empathy for
yeah you know for people the downtrodden
and the oppressed
it leaves open the door to that
manipulation yeah
how was your talk with sam harris
influenced your view on free will
how does democracy work in a world where
people's lack of free will is becoming
increasingly exposed
via troll for troll farms cambridge
analytica etc
um i would say my talk with sam
has caused me to think a lot about
why we couldn't come to any sort of
resolution
on points that i thought we would find
uh
common ground more easily and i will say
maybe it's a defect
in me but i don't think
in rethinking my position there are very
few things in that conversation that i
think i got wrong
there are places where i think i didn't
do a good job of marshalling the right
argument
and i would do it differently if i had
it to do over
but overall my sense is
the free will discussion is
totally polluted by
a failure of precision that is to say
when we talk about a failure of good of
a free will
it's a question of are we talking about
a 100 absence which leaves you in one
landscape or
some amount which leaves you in another
and some amount can be very small
but that distinction between none at all
in which case one set of things follows
and
there is some but it's a struggle leaves
you in a totally different place
so i still am resolutely on the there is
some but it's a struggle
but i recognize the uphill battle in
convincing anyone who doesn't
hold that position or see that as uh
intuitively clear
um convincing them that it is so anyway
i think i feel like there's something
that is yet to be resolved out of that
conversation and i look forward to
getting there
somehow sec how long 40 months
i would like to get through uh let's at
least get through two more here
and um we'll make sure to come back to
some of these um next time before going
to the super chat from this hour
the colombian national front was an
agreement for the liberals and
conservatives to rotate
power to the violent partisanship in the
country can this history be used to
influence unity
sadly colombia still has issues even
after the colombian national front
i don't know this history at all and it
feels like a piece of history that
we should know um i
am interested to know more and actually
if
uh if the person writing this question
put something to chat
or uh or you know what's the moderator's
email
uh darkhorse moderator it's just
darkhorse moderator
darkhorsematter gmail.com if you had any
source
on um this history that would be very
interesting
to look at the history on the columbia
national front yeah but i would say
the word rotate there
um i i spot this as a vulnerability
that rotate is a bit like the chaotic as
opposed to sharing
yes um because
you'll get when you're in power you want
to move the needle as far as you can
because you're going to lose it and it's
going to move the other way yeah and so
this is sorry we've got cat madness
going on here yeah eating
eating cords oh goodness um but anyway
so i think the thing is the system's
design has to be really careful in order
to work and um close
prototype level um is
good enough to learn the lesson but it's
not good enough to be stable long term
so
anyway yes i would say it sounds like a
thematically related
um exercise but but i think it's it's
vulnerable at its inception
brett at evergreen you had the security
of being sure there was no actual
evidence of your racism
what if there is racism in your past to
be found
uh a 26 year old who was a troubled 16
year old would appreciate your advice
such an amazing question yeah that's a
great question um
you know it's awkward now because
if you come clean about this in some way
then there's always the question of
whether you're doing it cynically
but on the other hand everybody
understands
that youth involves stupidity
of many different kinds everybody used
to understand that everybody used to
understand it you're now being
persecuted for uh failures that frankly
everybody has in their past
and so um
i don't there's not a great answer to
the question i think in some sense
you're depending on people recognizing
that they don't want to be judged based
on what they were doing at 16 either
and to the extent that you are up front
about i'm not comfortable looking at
myself at 16
i'm not comfortable with what i see and
here's you know in your case the
you know the uh the racial stuff that i
no longer feel or believe and maybe i
didn't believe it then maybe i was
motivated to say it
for other reasons you thought you were
going to be cool or something like that
but you know look um
forgiveness and tolerance these are
essential
values and i will say we had a
very good friend in grad school you know
one of the people we were closest with
who had experimented in high school
with some of this you know white
supremacist stuff
i'm not sure i know this you do you've
just forgotten it because it's so out of
character with the wonderful person that
we spent all the time with
oh okay so anyway the point was
it was some kid yeah doing stupid stuff
and you know
we never once thought about holding this
against this person because
it just obviously was not consistent
with their values
and you know we have to have the ability
to
to let people grow up you know i mean
this is i mean we've written this
uh in the childhood chapter of our book
this is this is part of
this this is not something i've heard
elsewhere but this is part of the reason
that the screens and the social media
are so dangerous
is that it immoral in it memorializes
forever
all of the mistakes of youth and youth
and development are exactly the time
when you're supposed to be exploring
and if you don't make any mistakes then
you're not going to become a very
interesting or
or competent adult so you know obviously
actually playing around with racist
ideas is um
is a is a greater kind of error than a
lot of people engage with but everyone
makes some kinds of errors and some
people make much
graver errors than that depending on
what exactly your your
personal history of racism might have
looked like and
used to be that not just you know not
just the courts
but society could recognize uh that
forgiveness was actually the way
to a a more robust populace
rather than holding people accountable
for every single thing that they've ever
done
but something about this you know this
goes back to our being so visually
dominant as primates that once you've
seen it once you've seen it either in
video or even in text it's very very
hard to forget
and the fact that social media just is
persistent
that we're being shown evidence of
everything from you know police
brutality
to some kids you know
exploration that wasn't socially okay
but it was a kid's exploration from a
long time ago
uh is causing people to glitch out and
forget that actually
we're supposed to be able to try to
understand and forgive
and heal and we're moving away from all
of those things
yeah i guess i would say three final
things
one check out helen pluck rose's
tweet thread from last week in which she
describes
her own path to becoming the
highly insightful courageous
adult that she is anyway it's absolutely
extraordinary
uh second thing i would say is check out
majid noise friend of ours
and his path from being a
uh a muslim he's an islamic extremist he
was an islamic
extremist and he realized the error of
his ways and
he is spending his uh adult years
um trying to make the world a better
place including a
recent very successful hunger strike
in defense of the uyghur in china
which forced the british parliament to
debate the matter i don't know
how it's come out but anyway it's quite
an extraordinary thing
and i would also say there's a lot to be
said
for um
finding people that you
had these prejudices against and
um who are uh
willing to see you for who you are and
you know correcting any residual
prejudice and
being candid about where you were i
think you might find it
uh cathartic
okay on to this hour's chat questions
love you guys
power to the people wolf and the whole
fam hang in there
thank you yeah there she is people wolf
on the jax live episode on eric's
podcast eric weinstein said something
along the lines
that evergreen was a failed experiment
you both have phds from university of
michigan
so higher tiered universities were
available to you uh question mark
so why evergreen that's
there's a lot to talk about there yep uh
i'm not sure what sort of three bullet
points since we're not going to spend an
hour talking about that here
but well one um
heather certainly could have gotten a
job at a higher tiered place and in fact
she did get
two job offers evergreen being one of
them which is
not common you know this is without a
postdoc she got two good offers
right out of the the gate i didn't have
my phd yet so
um anyway
the problem is the deal
that comes along with these jobs is not
nearly as desirable as you think
everybody sees the professor who
succeeded
late career has a certain amount of
freedom and thinks i want that job
but a there's less freedom now for even
people with a fair amount of power in
these departments
and b the road there is just appalling
yeah
i guess like like i said there's we
could talk for hours about this and
maybe it's worth doing so at some point
um because it does
it is revealing about the state of
higher ed right now but um
two things two anecdotes um
evergreen was not just some
b-roll vanilla liberal arts college
it was actually uh completely unique
in what you could do there and um so
uh you know failed experiment yeah
ultimately it was but there's no place
else
that has even come close to doing what
we could do there and a few other
faculty were doing there
because of the full-time programs
largely there are a few other
things that are unique to the curricular
structure there but mostly being
full-time with your students
and then i will also say my first year
at evergreen i was invited back to
michigan along with two other recent phd
graduates to be on a panel talking about
uh what life after graduate school looks
like if you've gone to academia
and so there was there's me at a liberal
arts college
there was someone in r1 you know a major
research university with the expectation
of low teaching
high research etc and then there was
someone at sort of a
mid-tier public university um
and you might think that the mid-tier
public university would be the sweet
spot but now it seemed like by far the
worst
like this woman had
you know an incredibly high teaching
load and incredibly high research
expectations and none of the um the
clout
or the respect that she might have had
if she'd been at either you know an r1
or a different kind of respect that you
get when you you know really dive deep
at a liberal arts college um and so each
of us basically gave little
little statements and then we fielded
questions from at that point there's
still
current phd students in the department
of biology at michigan
and the person who was at an r1
started out by saying if you take one of
these jobs
you can do this and one of the one other
thing so choose one thing
if you want a family you can do that
you're not going to do it great but you
can do it
if you have a hobby that you really love
you can do that but you can't have a
family
and you sort of went down the list of
some other things that you could do
and you know maybe maybe that was a
little bit extreme
but i'm not sure at all and i'm actually
not sure that you could even have two
things
like you know the the expectation of
work
uh in in a research university doing an
active research job um of you know 80
100 120 hours a week
and um and increasingly having
incredibly high governance
requirements as well which is to say you
know attending meetings and
leading committees and all of this um
seems so
far from actually doing science that uh
it doesn't
it doesn't look in any way enjoyable
and you know i i could have done the
work
it was enough in my wheelhouse that i
could have done that work but i don't i
would never have enjoyed it
i don't think it was even in your
wheelhouse to do it not that you aren't
all right what did you make more capable
of the science than
you know perhaps any other human being
on the planet but the idea of the
logistics involved
would have would have rendered it
impossible for you yeah it would have
been it would have been terrible
um i think the other thing though and
you know you sort of
blew right past it is evergreen had lots
of problems
it did not pay well um it fostered a lot
of nonsense because there were so many
you know this wasn't true at the
beginning of the college but at the
point that we arrived there there were
already a huge number of people who had
these jobs who didn't
have any interest in making anything any
use of the freedom that they had yeah so
anyway it was like an obstacle course
but
the freedom that we had to build
programs
that suited us suited our students did
what we wanted to do
i mean literally imagine this no
administrator can tell you
what to teach or how to teach it as long
as
students are showing up right if you
want to figure out
how to do something totally different
evergreen was essentially the only place
you could do that
without having to get somebody to sign
off on it i've never heard of another
place like that
you have an idea you put it in the
catalog and if students sign up you do
it
i mean yeah you know and this and it was
it was very real freedom and so
um you know absolutely possible to screw
it up it'd be possible to teach things
nobody cared to learn
and have nobody show up but for us you
know we always had waiting lists
so we had lots of interested students
who would show up
people bounced back and forth between
our programs and then we would teach
together and so
there was always people who knew our
style of thinking well
brand new people mixed together it was
just amazing it was
really dynamic and you know i never
never worried that i wasn't making a
difference
that's right doing something that
mattered it was never had trouble
sleeping at night because of the work
you were doing
right and it was always interesting
right the fact is every day
every week different every program
different every year different
absolutely and you know imagine
a college in which your professor knows
you as a human being
and actually spends time thinking about
what your obstacles are what you might
be misunderstanding
and how to teach in such a way that you
actually can understand the thing you
don't yet get
right that's not possible at four
credits at a time but that is possible
when somebody is with you for a full
year at full time you know when you go
into the field
together right so when you literally sit
around campfires together yeah you
literally sit around campfires or you
know
when uh you know you're lost in the
amazon and your
class figures out how they're going to
you know divide up the forest
and uh you know search it systematically
to
find you as night has fallen you know so
this wasn't either of us this was a
couple of our students once right yeah
well but i mean you know
just just lest you imagine that our
students were out searching for us who
had gotten ourselves lost in the amazon
no
no i i have been lost in tropical forest
a number of times but i always managed
to find my way out but
um but nonetheless the
thing that we were doing looks so little
like normal college teaching that when
people ask us why the heck were you at
evergreen it just it's hard to answer
because the fact is we were doing
something that was
uh amazing it was exciting it was
productive it made a difference in
people's lives
and you know yeah that college came
apart it doesn't exist anymore
but it did exist when we were there and
we made good use of it
yeah do you have any insight into recent
possible life signs in the venus
atmosphere could it be little green
women instead of little green men
well if it's only one it's it's gonna be
female um
but uh um good yeah
well it is it is i'm going to have very
little to say about it i mean that's
just the case even just as we were
talking about loneliness only
potentially um turning you into a
parthenogenic lifestyle effectively if
you're female it doesn't work if you're
male
wait a second uh-oh were you saying that
it was going to be
uh female because
because women are from venus or were you
saying it's going to be female because
of the part that's part of the
parth and the genesis yeah it's the
parthenogenesis okay so it just happens
to dovetail with that trope
yeah okay yeah if if we had just
possibly found life in the atmosphere of
mars it would still be um
little green i guess little red females
right not men okay now in this case
though we're talking about
i'd actually forgotten about the you had
i thought you had and then it
hit me that maybe that's what you were
getting at but um
we're talking about microbial life yeah
right well yes
so probably so i mean let's see like
microbe is like plankton right like it's
this yeah it's
just like a junk term that doesn't speak
to much beyond it's just tiny and
right yeah but unlikely it's sexual
unlikely yeah yeah so it's uh so
probably neither male nor female but if
it were one uh
it's it's female um
yeah i don't i don't know much beyond i
saw that uh there's
uh there's a possibility and that's
exciting so
i must tell you i you know it hadn't
even occurred to me that i was not
paying attention to the story until this
question shows up because i definitely
saw
the headline and i thought so little of
the likelihood that we have found
anything
meaningful on this front especially you
know this isn't mars
this is venus yeah it's very
inhospitable yes um
it's it's a little bit hot it's hot it's
not
um so anyway my i think my thought was
something like
um i can imagine a flurry of excitement
about this
i can imagine the near certainty that
it's not
right um i can't quite imagine what the
data were that suggests this possibility
i'm curious as to what people you know
on mars periodically somebody will find
a structure in the rocks and they will
say it's reminiscent of a bacterial
colony and it turns out a geological
process can do it
um so i guess i'm expecting exactly that
to unfold here i don't know what the
evidence is
and i know less about what kind of
what kind of evidence might be left
atmospherically than sort of
geologically right like i
i understand better what kinds of
evidence will look like
at the like paleontological
archaeological geological level than
atmospheric so
but i mean okay so maybe i also misread
the what little i read here but was this
a new mission to venus
that descended through the atmosphere
and collected something
and sent back some data or was this
the analysis of something that had
already
occurred i don't know hey zach if you're
seeing anything in the chat that
addresses that question tell us okay
with regard to possible life signs in
the atmosphere of venus
uh where is the what's the evidence
coming from
yeah so i think the answer to your
question is um
a dereliction of duty on both our parts
as biologists hearing that there might
be life on another planet
in our solar system and not having paid
enough attention
to it but i chalk it up to smoke
poisoning smoke poisoning
and you know having been through this
many many times
with mars i would say betting on this
not being what people think it is
um and the propensity of headlines to
get written
um because it would be very exciting if
there was life so
so exciting to think about somewhere
else even
hot hot hot venus yes yes
okay well we're getting we got to get
through a few more of these we barely
started
um starting my math masters my preferred
area requires three courses with
allegedly terrible professor
do you have survival advice what i take
now decides the course of the degree
i am worried hmm
the terrible professor problem is a
terrible problem yeah it really really
is
i never figured it out a mechanism and
there are so many of them
yeah there are so many terrible
professors and it's really much more
common than excellent professors
so that said sounds to me from your
question like this professor probably
really is terrible
but as i've said elsewhere my experience
in college
back in my day there used to be an
actual book
of reviews that classes and professors
had that you could look at to figure out
what course to take
and my experience was very frequently
the people i really thought were great
were not well liked
and the people that others thought were
great i found
boring or worse and so be aware that
it's possible
you know depending upon what terrible
means if terrible means the person's a
jerk
right and you know that they're they're
power hungry and they
you know yep or buy the book yeah and or
don't know their subject
right right any of those things and
that's just really bad on the other hand
polarizing
and works for some people doesn't work
for others maybe it'll work for you
yeah that's that's a that's a different
situation that's a different thing but
assuming it's not that
um you know can you take a summer course
instead that covers the same
material with a different person um can
you
teach yourself and then test out of it
um can you
uh go into some form of stasis
and emerge decades from now when things
have gotten better i don't know
something
i think that uh the recommendation to
former chrysalis
is probably not the best one um yeah for
technical reasons
for those who couldn't hear zach just
reads from the chat that is was observed
via telescope uh that a
signature of microbes that is known from
earth was also observed in the
atmosphere of venus is that right yeah
that better be some signature
or i'm betting against it yeah yeah
what if any legitimate scientific data
are the black lives matter leaders
and nick cannonites using to espouse
their claims that melanin is of the
utmost importance
and how are whites less than due to the
lack of neuromelanin
so i don't i barely recognize this name
not can i use nick cannonites but i
can't
i don't quite place it and you know i
mean this somehow this is the same
it's the same thing you know any
legitimate scientific data
that melanin is of the no no there's
nothing to it
of course not no um you know
i mean i guess actually it's not the
same all this just that just
if if the claim that we're being asked
is there any legitimate scientific data
to it
that melanin is the most important
indicator of who you are as a human
um and lacking neuromelanin i don't even
know what that means that's just that's
just [ __ ] but this is this is what
happens when you take
a a verificationist approach be licensed
to throw out whatever
you don't find convenient um and
see a a
bias in favor of simple mechanisms and
you try to apply them to a complex
complex system i would just say look
melanin is really really important you
know what else is important face shape
you know why because it allows people to
recognize
whether or not you're from their lineage
and we are predisposed
to cooperate with people who are more
closely related to us despite what my
colleagues may say
eye color right and build and maintain
low shape and you know what all these
things are indicators you can look at a
person on a subway and you can tell
whether
they're from you know uh
they're from europe they're from africa
they're from
asia and which part these things are
detectable and we all know it and the
point is they
are proxies for relatedness they are not
perfect but they are proxies
and the question is are we going to get
past
using these indicators to figure out
genetic relatedness and decide who is
our ally or are we not
that's the question so is melanin
important
mechanistically probably not very is it
important
as one of the components that people use
to recognize
uh kinetic distance yeah it's very
important but that's not the same thing
as
data that suggests it's an important uh
molecule
yeah um keep at it folks
what are your thoughts on nickland's
philosophy accelerationism and its
subtypes and or mark fisher's capitalist
realism
i have no thoughts on any of those
because i don't know what any of them
are well accelerationism
goddamn we know that one i don't um at
least not yet
basically it comes down to if you want
to make things better
makes it worse faster oh that's right
yes
um so this is a garbage idea in the
modern era
um because although it's true nothing
protects you from driving yourself
extinct with this
and the fact is we've got so many
systems that are so powerful that
are so inter-related that
driving things to dysfunction is very
likely to create
uh a catastrophe so in some sense if you
want to fix things you're obligated to
do it without
taking apart the system on which we are
all depending i mean the simple fact
that um more than half of the human
population
uh is present because of the haber bosch
process which has taken inorganic
nitrogen from the atmosphere and made it
biologically available in the form of
fertilizer which then creates foods that
we eat
you are you ready to take responsibility
for disrupting that process
right you can't so accelerating
dysfunction is is an insane idea in
2020.
so let's get through there's just a
number of comments here that
we won't have a lot to say about i don't
think um let's get through
three more questions here ending with
that one how would you write a character
like wolverine from marvel comics
without violating the laws of senescence
love your content keep it up so i will
admit and i'm not maybe you know more
than i do but i also just
just don't know enough about
marvel comics or that character to
say anything smart about it i really
like i really know almost nothing
and not not because i have because i you
know resistant
yeah unlike say disney princess land
which i am resistant to
um i'm not resistant to marvel universe
just haven't gone there if we had male
children we'd know more about them
i don't know why they haven't forced us
yeah i mean i guess
did we watch one movie maybe i don't
know i don't know we should probably we
should probably figure this out
um but um i suspect
wolverine is in some way immortal
hey zach do anything about wolverine
wow you will if you have male children
okay um yeah so our 16 year old producer
uh does not know anything about
wolverine absolutely nothing we can call
toby and our 14 year old he might know
something he might know something
the 16 year old knows that the 14 year
old knows nothing which sounds just like
a big brother
does it not it does this has gone
weirdly meta
um yes okay okay um have you already
discussed the philadelphia statement
this is going so well i don't know i
don't know
i we don't know what philadelphia i feel
like we'll know what that means yeah
moments ago you've got family in
philadelphia your dad grew up in
philadelphia you you went to
pennsylvania you've got so many friends
in pennsylvania um
i don't know what it is i'm sorry okay
zach's looking it up
we will go on i feel i did actually
encounter this earlier in the week
okay
uh haven't looked into it been too busy
sorry i feel like we've fallen down on
our responsibility as
podcasters it is but you know no but
there i mean there's a lot of
there's a lot of diversity of things
coming at us here
hopefully somebody will ask us about the
um
self-destruction of the columbia
marching band because that i feel
qualified to address
okay how about this we're gonna answer
two more questions here
and uh or maybe and then you will riff a
little bit on the columbia marching band
and then we'll find one more
to answer today set myself up for that
now yep you did you did
read the new york times article your
coronavirus test is positive maybe it
shouldn't be
it makes a case that 85 to 90 of cases
aren't contagious and don't need to
isolate
that this isn't major news suggests that
we're in a dystopia
so it's a weird headline i have not read
it um i can imagine what the argument
probably is i mean
given that you what this person says the
argument is
does not mean that the test shouldn't be
positive but that we should be
understanding that there are gradations
of of uh basically virulence
and that um actually there's a piece we
didn't end up talking about today
um a new piece of research out that
suggests that actually mask wearing
is even more effective than we thought
um because it actually um and we've
talked about other versions
of this before but that um people who
are wearing masks and people in places
where
everyone or almost everyone's wearing
masks have um not just lower rates of
transmission but
much lower rates of hospitalizations
and and really bad cases of the thing
and so this has to do with the
density dependence the viral load
argument um and so
probably this is related to that that
many people who have it have
a mild case and that a mild case
effectively acts like a kind of
inoculation so that you end up with
immunity that the headline i saw
suggested that you get immunity from
masks which is an insane headline
you don't get immunity from masks you
may get inoculated
such that you end up with a mild case
such that you don't get you aren't
infectable again
um because you were wearing a mask but
not because the mask itself conferred
immunity
um yeah i don't know more than that well
um so i worry
about this sort of conclusion there
because this is so politicized
people are looking for anything that
pulls in their direction
and they are not being careful about how
strongly it pulls in their direction so
what i worry about
is it is probably true
a the tests are garbage and false
negatives and false positives are so
um common i mean especially false
negatives i would say
that it's very hard to say what these
tests do and because we don't have
really good tests it's hard to test
other tests for what they're actually
implying but the
concern i would have is that infections
go through
phases and that they are highly
infectious
it's some uh limited for some limited
span
in the middle and that therefore you
would find people who still test
positive either side of that highly
infectious phase
and you might say aha their test was
positive but they're not infectious but
the point is
if everybody who has the infection
goes through a period in which they are
likely to infect others then it is not
true that because your test is positive
it is misleading the point is your test
is indicating that you have an infection
that goes through a stage at which you
are capable of infecting others
and that's um you know hey we we know
this
right this is this is presumed
um that you are infected with the virus
um but that there are periods in which
you're uh
liable to transmit it to others in
periods when you're not so anyway i feel
i'm rambling but
um the fact of
a period of high transmissibility and
the fact that you have the virus that
has that period are consistent with a
positive test
matty you're making it a little bit hard
to concentrate i'm really not trying to
encourage her
i think she thinks we've been on air too
long she may be right about that all
right i'm gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna just one more
question there one more question and
then
and then we're off then we're off no
columbia marching band
one more question what is the evolution
of hugging how far back the evolutionary
tree does it go and what is its function
i miss it hugely these days thank you
for the great podcast format
um i miss it too a lot i mean we we are
tactile creatures
and um and this is this is very hard
from a tactile perspective well tactile
and a bunch of other things too the fact
that
outside uh you're wearing masks which
blocks a whole bunch of
so much sensory data are missing data
transmission and all that
um yeah and just the simple fact even
even if you take out the other things
that you're looking at people
and if somebody coughs you know you have
to sense that they are a hostile
force yeah and all of this so uh
what is the origin of hugging i mean i
think well i know i mean we know that um
at least jumps and bonobos hug
um and actually franz duvall's most
recent book mama's last hug is about a
um an old chimp
uh who upon having her
former friend trainer i'm not sure what
person human
um come back to see her as she is dying
many many many years
after they have ever seen each other um
through her sort of
dying eyes she sees him and lights up
and reaches out to him and hugs him and
there's there's video of this and it's
it's extraordinary yeah um and it you
know it is
in in that book it does the service of
discussing um
the you know the the prevalence and
depth of emotion in non-human animals
um but it also reveals that you know
hugging is and we see this between
between germs between bone elbows i
think between gorillas
yep i don't orangs are at least on i
think borneo solitary and that's where
we know most of our orang behavior from
so
um they're less solitary elsewhere but i
don't i don't know if they hug
um yep gibbons probably at least hug
their pair bond
um right so gibbons which are certainly
needed for it
um i don't know all primates do a lot of
touching yep
but i would also point out yeah um this
is tangential to your question but i
find it so compelling
that uh i think it's worth introducing
the fact that there are numerous
examples
of um
great apes in captivity especially
gorillas maybe it's all gorillas
who have had a relationship with a cat
right yeah that these relationships make
sense that a domestic cat
is wired however it
occurs whether it's in the genome or
just simply through observation to treat
relationships with apes as normal
because people are apes
and you know they just simply do it
without thinking
and that a gorilla for whom presumably
having a
pet cat would not be normal nonetheless
gets the same thing out of it that you
know we humans do
and that these bonds form so easily and
you know so it's not so crazy to see a
you know gorilla holding its kitty cat
right suggests something about you know
the the universality of these things and
therefore
the ancientness of the behavior patterns
in the apes you know because we're
separated from
guerrillas by i think ten thousand
million
ten thousand what the hell man it must
be the smoke
uh yes ten million years um
so anyway it's a very ancient pattern it
covers at least most of the great apes
back through gorillas yeah
um and possibly farther and you know
that that suggests you know we have
basically not answered your question but
i think at some level the answer is
that the emotional uh charge you get
from
hugging is
valuable for the obvious reasons and
that that particular mechanism
has a long probably unbroken history
that goes back 10 million years is
pretty
pretty fascinating yeah no that's that's
right
all right well this is a weird one yes
sorry guys um here we are at the end
at the end um we will probably be back
on tuesday
uh today is tuesday oh my god we are not
coming back on tuesday
we are probably going to be back on
saturday saturday almost certainly yep
um at which point i think it will have
rained here and perhaps our brains will
have returned somewhat
normal i can hope that would be
marvelous wow um please consider
joining us at our patreons uh
to get access to the discord server or
join mine uh
to access the private monthly q and a's
like subscribe comment all of that
and uh you know be well and if you're
not
in if you're not on the west coast enjoy
breathing on our behalf
yes yes do that yes all right be well
everyone
you